I remember the first time I saw her I
felt like I'd known her my whole life
kind of fell in love with her couldn't
wait to see her again and again they
took her away
she showed me what a loving relationship
actually looked like I miss her every
day
not even magic can bring her back when
she found happiness it gave me hope you
know mmm it all ended
I am affected I am affected I am
affected since 1976 65% of all queer
female television characters have died
according to Auto straddle comm in 2015
alone 24 queer female characters have
been killed on television already in
2016 there have been 12 that's how many
more how many more how many more how
many more all of them okay we deserve
better so we wanted to give the writers
out there some more options for their
queer female characters like just not
killing them maybe or you can have that
straight bullet missed them and hit
someone else or change give them an
identical twin have them get their
master's degree that can take them out
of it like a season or two they pull a
groin muscle just from wonderful sex why
not a gay ghost I would love to be
haunted by a lesbian let their spirit
live inside a cat have them go to a
carnival they can grow old and have a
family and a dog and sit on a porch and
drink iced tea you can go to make
protectv I think that would make for
great TV please please please stop
killing queer female characters
she's not the same okay her marriage is
dead